kruzifix sapperlot leg mich fest die csu
ist plötzlich cool ja wirklich freunde
dank armin der armin ist moderator des
neuen hippen csu youtube kanals csq ein
wortspiel wegen csu und youtube wenn man
das zusammen tut ich glaube es selbst
erklärt hier wird jedenfalls die kesse
bildsprache der backfische und
halbstarken gepflegt klima ikone greta
abramowitsch ist diese woche mit einer
million ja das yacht club de monaco in
new york angekommen und klimaneutral
leider nein ja wir waren ein bisschen
wenig lustige geräusche für mich ein
frecher hund dieser armin wo bitte hat
die alte ranzige csu den diesen freshen
hipster ausgebuddelt
schön dass armin petzschner sich
vorstellt wir hätten ihn fast nicht
erkannt denn vor kurzem sah der social
media chef der csu-landesgruppe in
berlin noch so aus so schnell geht das
brille weg flasche wasserstoffperoxid
über die rübe gekämpft ja und schon hast
du statt einem langweiligen spießer ein
langweiliges spiel mit blonden haaren
ja
der sattel so adrian philipp am tor
er kommt wir lässt hat andererseits es
ist ja nie verkehrt ich sag mal komplexe
csu themen jugendgerecht aufzubereiten
warte mal was gab es denn da diese woche
richtig an die chance gescheiterte pkw
maut wird jetzt noch teurer für uns alle
klarer fall für den armin oder wieder
hat keinen bock machts halt eher gernot
[Musik]
servus und herzlich willkommen über ruhm
ist daheim in den bayrischen inzell
was ist denn los mit dem steuer an die
unserem verkehrsminister oder wie ich
ihn nenne ihn verkehrtminister anstatt
abzuwarten wie der ogh in sachen mode
urteilt hat sein laden noch vorher
verträge gemacht für die wir alle einen
arsch voll geld zahlen
alle experten die nicht völlig verblödet
sind haben wir sagt einer aussendung
audi keine ausländer benachteiligt
geht's nicht genauso wenig wie einen
coolen csu kanal dafür könnte im
nachhinein seines activesync markt kommt
aber wenn sie nicht kommt die wandel und
die maut ist im koalitionsvertrag ist
sie ganz beruhigt die maut kommt
überhaupt nicht lustig weil die
betreiberfirmen wohl nach dem stopp der
maut noch verträge mit subunternehmen
gemacht haben wird jetzt noch teurer
die blogger maut dieser bayerischen
bierzelt furth kostet und zwar
scheinlich eine halbe milliarde das ist
eine 5 mit 8
was sagt man dazu gesprochen
direkt danke geht gar nix kriegt er
gebacken
andys einziger erfolg in der innenstadt
stolper ich jetzt alle drei meter über
kaputte elektro roller mit denen sich
besoffene studenten auf die fresse legen
lassen
ich steck dir deine blöde zufrieden mit
anlauf in diesen zeiten
[Applaus]
[Musik]
michael de schreibt auf facebook wilke
du bist der letzte arsch nur große
fresse ich möchte ich mal sehen wenn es
hart auf hart kommt dann schaust du dir
in die hose warte ab ein sprichwort sagt
man trifft sich immer zweimal im leben
mach weiter so mit einer großen fresse
wie können warten
sehr geehrter herr b man sieht sich im
leben nicht nur zweimal sondern jeden
freitag um 22.30 im zweiten oder hier
auf youtube wenn sie uns abonnieren